Today, Joe Biden will be announcing multiple
executive actions on guns on firearm safety.
It may already have happened by the time you
listen to today's show or watch today's clips.
This is already angering many people. But it has
to happen because we have a gun violence crisis
in this country. We have a gun culture crisis
in this country. One of the actions Joe Biden
is expected to take is to deal with what are
called ghost guns, guns without serial numbers,
sometimes which can be made at home. Biden
is expected to direct the administration to
start a process that will require buyers of
so-called ghost guns to undergo background
checks. A question remains about exactly what
Joe Biden is going to do. And again, but by now,
meaning when you're listening to today's show, we
may already know a Biden previously called on the
Senate to pass stricter background check rules.
The House has already passed them. These would
make background checks apply to every gun sale
and transfer. It would give the FBI more time to
conduct background checks. Whether something
related to that will be part of the orders,
we just don't know yet. Joe Biden might announce
some regulations on concealed and or assault style
firearms, maybe prohibitions on firearm purchases
for those convicted of domestic violence against
partners. Maybe something about alerting law
enforcement agencies when potential buyers
fail background checks that these are people you
may want to keep an eye on as they may try to
obtain a firearm some other way, potentially
federal guidance on home storage safety
measures. There's a whole bunch of possibilities
and we'll know them very soon if we don't already.
But what we can be absolutely certain of is
that a huge portion of the American right wing
will be against whatever Joe Biden announces.
They will say all the things that they always
say. And to prepare you for that, we need to not
lose sight of the big picture. Whatever Joe Biden
announces or announced today changes nothing about
the Second Amendment. We have a Second Amendment.
People have a right to own firearms. None
of Joe Biden's orders will change that. Joe
Biden essentially has no choice but to do this.
And why think back to the Sandy Hook shooting.
When Democrats had the White House under Barack
Obama, the House of Representatives, the Senate,
and nearly 90 percent of Americans supported
a law for universal background checks. Such a
milquetoast thing, such a basic thing, Democrats
still couldn't get it done because of opposition
from Republicans, because of opposition from the
gun lobby. If you can't get universal background
checks done in that environment after one of
the worst school shootings in American history,
controlling the White House, House and Senate and
having the American public on your side at an 88
to 90 percent level, which is almost unheard of in
the hyper partizan American political status quo.
I don't know that you can ever really get
anything done unless a president just says
I'm doing executive action. So this has to
happen. They will say Biden is coming for your
guns. They will say Biden is ending the Second
Amendment. None of it is true. But let's see what
Joe Biden does or did if it already happened,
depending on when you listen to today's show.
And then we will talk more about the implications
of what he does, what he does. But it has to
be done. There's no other choice. You know, you
hear from the right, some on the right say, well,
we should work together. The left, the Democratic
Party shouldn't act unilaterally. What choice do
they have when 90 percent of the country wants
background checks and Republicans still don't? So
once we know exactly what Joe Biden signs, we
will have more on this on The David Pakman Show
Instagram page. Make sure you are following us
there at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.